the mother of two Native American
teenagers removed from a college tour by
campus police says her sons are the
victims of racial profiling Thomas and
Lloyd gray were visiting Colorado State
University last week when officers
pulled him aside and searched them a
woman in their tour group had called 911
because she thought the young men were
acting suspiciously Jericka Duncan shows
us how the university is responding
Jericka good morning good morning CSU
officials say they are troubled and
angered that the brothers were made to
feel unwelcome in the interest of
transparency they released the 9-1-1
call and police body cam footage but
blurred the young men's faces to protect
their privacy thomas and lloyd grace a
colorado state university police made
them feel like suspects even though they
did nothing wrong during their campus
tour a mother on the tour group reported
the young men to campus police saying
they were dressed in black and were
quiet and evasive when she tried to ask
them questions and kicked nothing i'm
sorry
that they'd like it actually made me
like so sick and i've never felt like
that are they white males I think there
has been I believe one of them for sure
he said he's from Mexico
the brothers are musicians and members
of the Mohawk tribe they drove about
seven hours from their home in New
Mexico to take the tour officers let the
17 and 19 year olds go only after they
showed an email confirming their tour
schedule the way that they were talking
to Lloyd that it could have pretty much
escalated quickly Thomas and his younger
brother Lloyd both say they are now
hesitant to return to the CSU campus
CSU's president said in a statement
there is no place for hate at Colorado
State University and we will not be
silent when we see it I felt like they
treated my boys like garbage
despite her anger Lorraine Gray says
she's glad the situation did not end
worse for her sons I'm one of the lucky
mothers who still has experienced
something like this with law enforcement
and still
my boys alive and there was no reason
for suspicion
except for this 911 bias the University
says from now on no one on a campus tour
will be questioned and less officer
speak with the tour guide first CSU also
wants to reimburse Thomas and Lloyd for
their expenses and bring them back to
campus as VIPs the brothers told us
they're unsure if they'll accept that
Nora all right Joe Rica thank you